I thank you for coming to my talk
organized I introduced me so I came from
London UK I work as a data scientist for
a start-up and I came here to get to
give a talk about Russian truth weights
so I'll give some background on my talk
as we all know social media platforms
Facebook Twitter reddit exploded in
popularity and they give a great option
to people to connect and to interact
with each other however social media
platforms also provide a forum for
agenda building so push pushing your own
issues to be the issues of policymakers
and also we are all aware of different
kind we are all aware of different other
different propagation of house and
harmful information for example trolling
where usually people troll women gender
minorities LGBTQ community other people
that have some kind of yet not fit into
the social standards also hate speech
all these groups are targeted with hate
speech and of course in recent years we
have explosion of fake news fake news as
as a phenomena is not new however in the
recent time it has become the main issue
where even politicians are allowed to
publish to publish arts where they can
basically say what they want and
Facebook will allow it
researchers are trying to not use the
term fake news and according to
information disorder framework they
usually classify fake news into
misinformation disinformation and mal
information so misinformation is when
false information is shared without
intent so you get some link you think
it's ok and it's true what it says and
you say to a friends without any
intentions to to spread it the actual
false information then we have this
information where people intentionally
share false news and mal information
when true information is shared in order
to harm someone for example that would
be hate speech next slide shows some
background to the data set and the talk
so from Russia with troll in January
2017 United States Office of the
Director of National Intelligence
published the classified report there is
also classified version which is not in
public domain and the report gives a
background to assessing Russian
activities and intentions in u.s.
elections particularly it gives
assessment of the extent and basis of
Russia's interference in United States
elections in 2016 and the report
examines the utilization of online space
for hacking and the use of internet
trolls and BOTS
and media campaign to influence public
opinion in the US next year in February
2018 US Justice Department charged 13
Russian Russian nationals and three
entities with interfering in American
electoral and political process
according to the official report and
also news reports defendants worked for
the internet research agency or troll
Factory in st. Pete st. Petersburg in
Russia basically internet research
agency conducts online operations on
behalf of Russian business and political
interests and now that we mentioned
trolls and BOTS I'll give some
definitions online trolls are
predominantly human or semi-automated
user accounts that behave in deceptive
destructive and or disruptive manner in
the social settings on the internet
according to buckles while social bots
are also predominantly automated systems
that pose as humans and seek to
influence human communications and
manipulate public opinion there is also
one category between out and fully
automated and human but because some
companies might use BOTS to for their
marketing purposes
so that would be cyborgs which are kind
of curated by humans but sent a lot of
automated messages and the
characteristics of the bots is actually
that they sent a lot of messages
although some humans treat a lot as well
Trump sent 105 tweets on Saturday so
yeah
I don't know if that's automated or the
activity of trolls and BOTS it's not
mutually exclusive and researchers found
researchers on Russian influence
interference uncovered that actually
both BOTS and the trolls were used
across Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and Google as well their intention is to
weaponize social media propagate
state-sponsored propaganda and
destabilize foreign politics for this
talk I have been looking into the
Russian troll tweet dataset it has three
million tweets just under three million
two million nine hundred and eighty
something tweets and these are the
tweets associated with the internet
research agency twitter handles it was
there were two thousand eight hundred
and forty-eight Twitter handles data
collection and initial research was done
by Linville and Lauren from Clemson
University in South Carolina what they
did is when the US National Intelligence
released assessment report
they took notice of the Twitter handles
that were published and then collected
the data on these handles and published
the paper troll factories their internet
research agency and state-sponsored
agenda building data set was made
available last year by 538 website and
it is open data this is how one
researcher commented on the release of
the data set and
[Music]
I will be talking with regards to this
data set on the troll accounts different
categories and their agendas what kind
of information they disseminated and
we'll have a look at the timeline of
their activity and at the end I'll give
some details on importance of this
research and challenges for the those
involved in this research so how this is
how the data frame looks we are all
familiar with data frames and Python and
everything so it doesn't have a lot of
variables it has auto content region
language published a date harvest days
following followers updates account type
account category it doesn't give for
example accounts bio from where we can
might we might get more information also
it doesn't give latitude or one get
longitude it has a region but that is
not we cannot really rely on that
because a lot of accounts has have
regions as unknown and we are not quite
sure if they are actually the places
where they tweeted from tweets also used
a lot of languages I haven't got the
graph here but one of the most prominent
languages was Russian for example but
also German polish Spanish over 30
languages 40 different languages there
are trolls itself
they were categorized into eight
different categories right through left
troll newsfeed hashtag a mafia manga
and also we have some other categories
like commercial non English and unknown
however for the purposes of this
analysis I have concentrated on five
main categories because some data on the
other categories obviously are
non-english it might be analyzed with
some and I'll take a libraries with
other languages but this is only like
focus on the main categories and here
you can see the distribution there is
quite a lot of non-english tweets so for
example one might say why would
how can a message written on serbian or
polish be relevant to Americans but I
guess it it it just contributes to the
out to the amplification of the message
and to sharing and for example if it's a
Spanish language we have become a big
part of us where people speak Spanish so
that's white it might be relevant for
that reason these accounts they they
treated in different way so each
category or almost each category stick
to their own agenda so for example I
have concentrated on the five categories
and we'll have a look at each one of
them right Stroh's they mostly posted
naturist and right-leaning
populist messages so nativist is like
propagating to people who are native
inhabitants of the US not somebody who
has become naturalized they used hash
tags common to the to the real twitter
users so we have make America great
again
top conservatives on Twitter Patrick
journalist Network Christian
conservatives on Twitter or red nation
rising these accounts followed followed
all major accounts that are associated
with with the Republicans and also
supported Donald Trump his candidacy and
his presidency later on what is quite
interesting is that these tweets don't
have don't talk about traditional
Republican themes such as abortion tax
or regulation they also posted divisive
messages about moderate and mainstream
Republicans so yeah this is what the
main hashtags associated with right
trolls are you can see Mogga appeal
genetic code etc left straws on the
other hand and they posted socially
liberal messages with focus on cultural
and racial identity they tweeted a lot
about black lives matter black Twitter
and in a way tweeted to mimic the black
lives matter movement they also talked
about for example Ferguson shootings and
other similar events in the u.s. just
like right roles and devising messages
aimed at prominent Republicans left
roles also sent such messages aimed at
prominent Democrats so a lot of tweets
about Hillary Clinton to undermine her
and
also rumors about about her campaign so
yeah you can see here a lot of hashtags
apart from the ones that I mentioned
there were quite a lot of hashtags with
rap music hip hop so they kind of
researched researched well what to in
country in what to incorporate within
this these accounts and this is how it
looks in a word cloud now there there is
another category news feed through they
presented themselves as US local news
age a gregarious and they had handles to
reflect like local area Seattle Post
today Pittsburgh etc they posted links
to legitimate news sources and tweeted
about issues of local interest and world
news so for example something about some
Widow shows Arizona officer crash
Cruiser into suspect about us Democrat
LOC so yeah they only treated some kind
of news
hashtag i'ma these handles they they
involved entirely in playing hashtag
games on Twitter this is just like a
verdict lame game played on Twitter by
uses add a hashtag to tweet and then
answered some question however they also
posted some socially divisive messages
and tweets shared can be seen both in
the tweet said also reflected the team's
of those rights troll and left role
categories so yeah this is just like
some kind of
an example of hashtag game hashtags and
the last one is among those five is a
fear monger troll they spread news of a
fabricated event
particularly that some sound that
salmonella contaminated turkeys were
produced by [ __ ] for us poultry producer
near the 2015 Thanksgiving holiday and
the tweets mostly focused on most mostly
described how individuals got poisoned
by purchasing turkeys from Walmart and
the story was debunked by debunked and
indicated as era fabrication in the
difference to other accounts fear monger
trolls switched between categories so
they would treat different teams while
other categories they just stick to
their own topic so here that would be
twister for this is a basically
dimensionality reduction with the human
Python library which was released last
year and it's similar to t-sne so here
we can see clusters of the tweets and
I'm sorry the picture is not bigger but
yeah you can see how how categories are
nicely clustered although we can also
see just some bits interfering in two
different categories with their content
as for the timeline activity we can see
that the first tweet was posted quite a
few years before the election in 2000 in
February 2012 and the last tweets were
posted on the at the last day of May
2018 this is a basically went with
disable these accounts and there are
some days when accounts were when a lot
of tweets appeared and reached quite a
few peaks during the during the whole
timeline so this is visualized with
ggplot and Jian in our and it it shows
basically a calendar plot where you can
see how at the beginning in 2012 for
example we don't have in January any
trees as they started in February on
some days they weren't even active but
they were kind of present throughout the
air from time to time let's say make a
break and then go again the same goes
for 2013 and 14
although towards the end of 2014 we have
kind of daily activity especially in in
December you can see that they are
active every day and from the beginning
of 2015 you can see how the activity
increases and kind of gets in 2016
election year and yeah after it's
actually quite frequent and also you can
you can notice no
some days when the activity is really
high in 2018 day 18 they basically go to
the levels of three 2015 until the until
end of May when they were deactivated so
this is basically another way of showing
this and we can see some peaks so I
looked at the particular dates to see if
we can relate some world events to these
Peaks and here we are so we have a white
one quite significant peak in April 2016
this happens after the after they went
when DN s G and C Democratic National
Committee was there basically Chairman's
account got hacked and they Russians got
hold of of the gmail account details and
all the content obviously so it is kind
of quite significant ich afterwards then
we have like a usual activity kind of
getting a bit low in in July of 2016 and
after the Republican convention where
Trump won the presidential nomination
these tweets are gradually building so
you can see how the frequency increase
increases and there is the biggest week
in October 2016 here indicated with
green color this is when WikiLeaks
who forwarded the data started actually
publishing Podesta's emails and
throughout this process this remains the
the highest duty with the highest
activity and it's the tweets almost
started in a matter of hours and then we
have obviously presidential election
Trump wins and kind of quite active
tweets after that this is also activity
for the of the accounts for the hour of
the day so we can see that within a 24
window they were mostly active in the
afternoon and night so after 8 o'clock
that would be for example West Coast you
say people are it's morning
so tweets mostly posted in the afternoon
and late evening actually to coincide
with the US time and if we look at the
hour of the week then the activity is
kind of bigger towards the end of the
week and in later hours as well so this
is what I talked about is mostly related
to us however some activity was found
beyond the US so there is some activity
related to Canada one journalist
identified eight thousand tweets
targeted at Canada we talked about where
they talked about refugees asylum
seekers border issue things like that
also in the UK where trolls target
and peace Jeremy Corbyn to resume John
McDonnell and Boris Johnson although
here campaign I was focused more on
controversy than on policy of these two
parties labor and conservatives some
tweets were active in Italy in Italy to
supports populist positions as well as
in Spain and Israel so talking about all
of this and saying how it can how this
campaign was state organized and
coordinated on a big scale we can see
that we can say that they are quite few
implications for societies for Western
societies as well for other society and
in society in the world and the main
issue is with interfering in democratic
processes affecting public opinion so in
discourse and propagating falsehoods and
harmful information researchers are
quite active in this area in the last
few years and they employ different
methods to tackle the problem because it
is a big problem some some methods
include engineering a large number of
features from the content and using
supervised machine learning models to
detect if a Twitter account exhibits
similarity to the known characteristics
of social BOTS there is a lot of
research for example published on
previously published on deception which
can be applied in some areas to to this
problem as well some research focuses on
semantic analysis of content
sequence analysis for example measuring
the similarities between the sequence of
tax generated over time against
reference set
also social sequence analysis as a way
to measure digital identity and I guess
quite important is also to quantify this
online influence because content gets
shared messages gets get amplified and
they reach white audience so there was a
one research recently which applied hoax
processes to measure online influence of
the Twitter trolls data set not this one
but the one race released recently by
Twitter ten million tweets and they
measured online influence links shared
from this data set on across reddit and
other platforms and obviously with with
such a problem there are a lot of
challenges different types of trolls and
BOTS and the role they play make it
difficult to differentiate between them
and understand their strategy so as any
software ages they can have different
strategies and change their behavior and
their role according to their creators
also language itself is constantly
evolving and spoken well every year we
have some new words added to the
dictionary so languages everywhere are
evolving so that might call for
retraining of the algorithm models and
of course BOTS are evolving too they are
using more sophisticated like language
it's difficult to distinguish between
automated and human our narrative and
also they are if they are employed for
propaganda they the experience shows
that they simulate multiple political
ideologies and other challenges that
classifiers may work on one set of
accounts and may perform well but then
they wouldn't perform well on another
set of accounts because they change
their behavior over time other big
problem is that state-sponsored roles
have influence on fringe communities
such as 4chan especially Paul board gab
community as well because the experience
shows that content posted by such
accounts account resonate with
communities there and the shooting at
the synagogue in the US last year well
it apparently the the shooter had he got
his ideology from being an active member
of gab another quite important challenge
is lack of open data sets because
sometimes researchers are reluctant to
share the data obviously Facebook has
restriction on its data unless you do
some research with them Twitter is kind
of quite
still quite open to for people to
research data but they are putting some
restrictions as well so yeah lack of
open data set is a problem as well
recently some data sets were released by
Twitter so they released state-sponsored
trolls datasets from Russia Iran and
Venezuela and another interesting data
set is data set that was used during the
protests in protests in Hong Kong which
was released quite recently so with this
I would say that it's a big problem
there are a lot of challenges and I
would like to thank you for the for
having me thank you for your
presentation we got time for one
question if someone
hi um so my question is do you have any
particular reason for selecting this
topic is it your personal interest or is
it connected to your job you said you
work in London so and you showed us data
about us so it's your party or personal
interest or is it take to connected to
your work it's not connected to my work
I like an LP but unfortunately I don't
do a lot of work at my job I think that
we should all be quite adamant in in
recognising fake news all kinds of
misinformation because it affects almost
everybody it's not just for political
reasons we have a lot of examples for
example where people create closed
groups on Facebook's misinformation
disinformation about vaccines so in the
last two years we have you know like a
lot of people are dying because they
don't want to be vaccinated just because
there is a lot of messages that say that
vaccines are not safe so yeah that is
obviously quite important and the forces
for society as a whole I guess that that
is important in a way that we shouldn't
rely on opinion but on facts and you
know just like not to fall for any kind
of discord
and yeah I like working with tax data
and and see how such actions affect the
societies I guess I answered your
question
thank you once again